[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
gabe spots weekly video game hangout i'm
your host mike mccarty here with yorm
the giant really bad boss fight from
dark souls 3. don't even try to argue it
uh but he's also our giveaway today uh i
wanted to be out of the office again i
can't stand him so
it's like 30 pounds pete disagrees with
me it's pretty heavy but this will be
our giveaway today um jump right into it
because he's kind of taking up the
conversation right here uh go to
gamespot's twitter account they're gonna
tweet out a link you can
uh you know apply there send in your
name and uh follow gamespot retweet it
and later on the week we'll pick the
winner and you might get yourm pete did
you play dark souls 3 no so you don't
know who yarmouth
i've seen yarm this is pete brown
reviews editor and uh he was not he was
fortunate enough to not have to fight
this dumb boss i'm bad at these games
it's he's he's dumb did you play dark
souls 3 kelly no i'm also bad at these
games it's kelly plaggy so it seems like
i'm the only one here that hates yorm
again we can get him out of here
if you want him you're really selling it
yeah no it's really cool this thing i
hate whatever it's cool he's uh he's got
no face you could put your finger in his
face hole uh his sword has a hole too
he's just
i don't like this boss at all in general
but it is a cool figure um it's like one
of those assembly ones you like you take
it apart and then put it back on it kind
of fell apart on accident here but it's
in good shape uh yeah anyway we have a
good show today we have horizon zero
dawn a lot of coverage on that game all
three of us have played it pete reviewed
it his reviews up we'll talk about that
we also have some berserk to get into
and uh
we're going to talk about some uh some
developers that are doing well in recent
weeks in the coming months i want to
just mention that there is this nice
like this is fibers i think it's
fuzzy the package said wolf hair like
actual wolf hair well i was kidding
but it feels
it feels real it looks like errant
mustache hairs that were collected off
someone's bathroom floor probably cool
you guys are not selling the statue
yeah follow gamespot twitter account and
then uh
retweet it follow
get a better shot of that his dumb face
hole
that's him that's yourm anyway
onto the show
okay
well done we have one more thing
uh so producers of the lobby brought to
my attention last week that i have a
foul mouth
and uh last week more so than usual so
what i decided to do is to institute a
swear jar in the form of this fallout
for
nuke it's the f-bomb
this is the f-bomb now
so if i swear too much i'll start
putting dollar bills in that
uh p-12 yes not like pete has a i mean
i have a pretty foul mouth
yeah sweet well hopefully
i don't know what we're gonna do with
money once he goes in there but we'll
figure something out yeah
all right
anyway
what have you guys been up to this week
uh man getting hyped for switch um and
trying to cool down from horizon uh i
know we're not jumping into that yet but
that game had me riding pretty high for
the last week yeah had me riding
dinosaurs robot dinosaurs striders i
killed a grazer before we came on yeah
uh this
this game in general is
pretty fantastic i play like four hours
of it i think you and me similar play
time yeah i really really like it i
didn't want to put it down i went to bed
super late i'm really tired worth it
i like it a lot a lot of thoughts well
for those just joining again we are
getting into more horizon then we're
going to be talking about uh
kind of like because guerrilla games
seems to have a hit on their hands and
it's a game and a genre that they're not
known for at all
in a series they're not known for uh we
are going to talk about developers today
on the scene that are pretty hot so to
speak but first i want to get into
a little lesser profile game but i'm
sure people are interested in it
nonetheless uh berserk band of the hawk
yeah you wanted to talk about this right
i wanted to because i don't know my
favorite game you two both played it
right yeah i played a couple hours a
little bit yeah yeah so it's based on
like a more than 27 year running manga
series i said manga before the show and
kelly yelled at me yeah rightfully so so
describe this series to me quick before
we jump into the game
i don't know uh
i mean in the series berserker is the
series band of the hawk the series is
berserk um it's known for being really
gory um
it kind of resurfaced due to a new anime
that aired last year uh and it was
controversial for having a lot of cg
that everyone hated it's basically all
scenes it was like all cg um but yeah
it's like as opposed to like purest
anime well yeah because there was a tv
series in the 90s that was rather
short-lived only told like part of one
arc of the manga yeah i mean it didn't
didn't go that far it's one of those
things that like some anime i'll be like
just read the manga this is probably one
of them for me but uh it's about a dude
named guts
and he just likes to kill people that's
a super simplification of it yeah
there's like a lot of occult stuff that
are that's brought into it and uh super
gory and you know like things like
demons and hell are very prominent i
mean like i want to emphasize how gory
and heavy it is like this is not
something you take lightly don't read it
like if you just want to like a little
romp you know so it fits because it's
part of like what is a spin-off of the
warriors series dynasty warriors uh were
mechanically similar to that
series because omega force did this as
well right right yeah and uh basically
yeah and berserk has got it or guts has
got a huge sword and he's just mowing
down enemies and that's basically what
you've always done in those games and
our review is up if you want to go read
it uh five five five out of ten from
miguel concepcion our editor here at
gamespot uh he seemed to find it
monotonous in banal after its first hour
or two actually considering the
like
extra content
yeah that's very much a common complaint
with musso games um but this one has a
lot of anime cut scenes in it um we're
just looking at some berserk right now
uh super long cutscenes right super long
cutscenes taken from the long history of
different anime and different arcs of
berserk and they actually did
tighten up the cg that was a big
complaint uh for the most recent
berserk anime adaptation
which i thought was interesting uh but
yeah yeah look at that those upturned
lips and that bulbous nose is not the
guts i know
that's not the best oh he looks
different than the one we're used to
slightly yeah there's like stylized
take on him and so like
you know it's the anime itself is
engaging like the the cut scenes are
enjoyable to watch despite like yeah i
love the older stuff but these are still
okay
in the context of the game but then you
only get about five to ten minutes to
play before you get thrown into another
cutscene oh that's like uh what game was
that surah's wrath did you play that
back in the day yeah that a little bit
but even that like the gameplay itself
was quick time events right exactly
interacts with different scenes
throughout the whole game but like to
contrast it with something similar like
i've played one piece musou games that
basically tell a very abridged version
of the one piece story if you don't know
one piece is that like episode 800 now
absolutely um still running uh
yes too many um
but like the one-piece museo games
kind of uh do these very short versions
of cutscenes and so it's not as broken
up as banner the hawk is um just for
context okay so so there are like side
objectives it looks like in this uh from
what you guys played how long did both
you play
i was only allowed to play about two
hours yeah why were you only allowed who
was preventing you from playing one
the tr company oh like a preview i was
doing i was capturing footage i got like
a two hours yeah i thought like his mom
limited his tv time
peter you played more than an hour of
berserk
i want to watch my stories
um
yep so you played it for a preview is
that the same thing or do you play like
post release
out yeah uh yes i sit next to miguel so
i just kind of swoop in on what he's
he's working on sometimes
um so i didn't even get two hours but
it's enough with the museo game like
it's pretty much enough to
get a feel for what it's going to be
the gameplay is pretty similar
throughout obviously and then i watched
a lot of the cutscenes just kind of over
his shoulder what's going on here is it
like a medieval kind of aesthetic yes
sort of i mean like you're
you're kind of like an orphan and now
you're a mercenary and you join this
this crew that is
essentially uh the leader is griffith
who sort of is like your long time like
ally rival from that point forward
um but you know like the gameplay is
basically this no matter what your side
objectives are this is kind of all
you're doing yeah and in a sense it does
kind of capture like the essence of guts
like he's covered in blood right now
there's blood flying everywhere he has a
huge sword right it makes a lot of sense
it makes a lot of sense and i think
maybe perhaps better than the berserk
games that were on dreamcast uh and the
japanese one on ps2 like this
feels like your your your guts a little
bit more but it just you don't really
get the same sense of like
the character rather than like what he
does
is he an interesting character in the
manga
he's certainly conflicted he's got a lot
of inner dialogue yeah you kind of get a
lot of it here um just through cut
scenes which is ambitious for these
games to try to like you know present a
story but it's especially for fans of
the series stuff they've already seen so
it does tread familiar ground which yes
it detracts from that a little bit
um and there's certain aspects of the
anime and manga that are hinted at or
sort of talked about for brief sense of
time even in those mediums that it's
like a video game that was exploring
just like the dark knight part of guts
would be awesome but it focuses so much
in the beginning well actually in the
very beginning he's in like hell yeah
but from that point forward it moves
towards him like you know being a
budding mercenary and that stuff berserk
fans have experienced forever and i
think
this doesn't even give them what they
want and speaking as a casual berserk
fan it doesn't give me what i want right
yeah and even like if you're like this
isn't going to be a good entry point for
berserk if you haven't been exposed to
it at all like again just to read the
manga that's my mantra so
i don't know how much of a dedicated
following like museo games have i mean
i'm sure they do but it seems like it's
so monotonous and i'm i feel like i'm
[ __ ] on it at all i i play them i
play them for like the catharsis of it
just kind of mowing through enemies and
it's like that relaxing kind of grind
sure does this game
cater well to fans of musa even if they
don't care about
so miguel has a pretty long history with
the series um i forget his exact points
but basically i think what he uh what it
boiled down to for him is in that
context
this doesn't maybe do enough to stand
out if you're just looking at it as like
a mousseau game yeah um i just speaking
from my experience if you look at attack
on titan that game that came out a
couple months ago at least that point
mobility has changed because you have
these things that propel you through the
3d maneuver gear right like you can just
fly all around the map i mean that feels
like a fundamental change where it's
like cool
this really
it talk about the ps4 one right yeah
yeah i mean this really just feels like
you're playing musou with the dressing
of berserk not necessarily that it's
influenced the gameplay
uh as much as the story in the setting
that's a good point gotcha okay well
that is berserk band of the hawk we'll
uh move on from that shortly uh our
review by miguel concepcion is up on
gamespot he gave it a five out of ten
you can go read a little more about that
we have gameplay videos up as well if
you're in the video
yeah the video reviews up on youtube and
game spot so go check those out and let
us know what you think and whether you
want to be playing it amid the slew of
releases on the near horizon slurry
what
what
that
you should pay for that one
yeah for those just joining this is our
f-bomb swear jar yeah because uh
apparently i swore a lot we all swear a
lot um all right here we go horizon zero
dawn probably what a lot of you came
here for today that's what i came here
for today nothing against berserk but
it's not it's no horizon
yeah because it got a 5 out of 10 on
gamespot.com horizon zero dawn got a
nine out of ten by none other than peter
brown right here yeah p we don't want to
reiterate your review too much but
let's sum it up i feel like
i feel like there's some stuff i wasn't
able to get through my review because
there's a lot to talk about in this game
um
okay so i played a lot of open world
games over the past couple of years and
that includes the likes of xenoblade
chronicles bengal sod 5 fallout 4
whatever
um
this is the first game that makes the
action so immediate and satisfying and
throughout the game that is what sort of
drive drives you to continue exploring
the world at least for me like
at no point did i ever grow tired of the
combat and
that isn't that's partially because eloy
the character controls so well but also
because she has a lot of different
weapons and the enemies are so great and
they have sort of an answer for
everything you throw at them so that's
like the one constant in this game that
that is always true and the second one
is
the world is just beautiful to look at
the game gorilla games knows what
they're doing their engine is amazing
and this is evidence of that um and so
beyond that what you have is an open
world game kind of like something like
far cry it's a series i don't have a lot
of experience with but you kept telling
me like oh it sounds like far
structurally it feels like a far cry
open world like cascading structure once
you unlock this outpost and then you get
this kind of side quest you're hunting
to upgrade your capacity for these
things right so yeah you spend the
action but definitely the overall
structure and systems at play yeah
crafting is huge resource gathering is
huge and sort of working towards being
able to carry more and do more with what
you carry
um and then on top of that there's a
story that maybe doesn't start out so
wonderful well actually the beginning is
great the middle part is a bit dull
but by the end it sort of goes uh into
areas that were hinted at at the
beginning of the game and it's like nice
to see them trade the tribal stuff for
like okay what's the deal with this
world why is this world like this
because it's this interesting mix of
as you can see like
wilderness but then also crazy
technology
um and it's a it's a marriage that is
also represented in eloy because you
know she is essentially an outcast from
this tribe um as a young child and this
is all the beginning of the game she
finds a device that essentially lets her
tap into technology which no one else
around her
has done or currently does she calls it
the focus yeah yeah i found her whether
it was the voice acting or the character
animation the character animations in
this game are kind of weird sometimes
like they skirt the uncanny valley a
little too much for me yeah but i found
her to be more interesting of a
character when she was younger well i've
only played as her for like two hours
right now i liked her when she was
younger i thought the way they
characterized her as a child was so true
to how children are and i was so charmed
by it like she's like repeating lines
that she hears and repeating the things
people say to her and it was just it
seemed very real to me sure um but i i
think her motivations are
like pretty well developed um at least
in the beginning to like get you going
and get you engrossed so yeah and and i
would love to spoil these things but i
can't so you know what i can say though
is that by the end of the game at least
the the third act it is it is so steeped
in um
eloy's story and the story of the world
that whereas yes i agree with you her
character kind of falls off after the
intro section
the game almost kind of
does it on purpose to let the world and
like the tribal stuff
come into play to make you feel like
okay i understand what's happening in
the present day but then the end of it
is all about history and stuff like that
and the stuff eloy learns and her
character
certainly comes around in a very
meaningful way for me and that's
probably a good segue because you kept
you keep talking about the world and the
post-apocalypse that's what i wanted to
talk about for this segment is
specifically uh how gorilla games uh the
amsterdam based developer has kind of
crafted this how do i say unique because
other people have done this but it's
crafted this in the slew of
post-apocalyptic games we have this is
kind of a novel take on the
post-apocalypse right i think they call
it the post post apocalypse yeah post
post so it's like a thousand years after
whatever event it's a thousand years
from now um and humans have you know
like not just dealt with and accepted
whatever it was whatever apocalypse came
about but they've adapted like back to
tribal warfare and politics they
actually have no idea why the world is
the way it is around them they've
accepted it this is how things are now
right machines they come up with their
own terms for things you know they refer
to things based on the metal places yeah
how it makes sense you know the old ones
referring to us yeah right it's just how
it makes sense to them at their point in
time it's it's not only us it's an
advanced form of us from what i've
gathered right like the focus thing is
kind of yeah so technically the year
i don't know if i can spoil the year
it's not exactly a thousand years from
today i think that a loading screen says
that they actually give you a certain
year that it's like a thousand years
from okay
but it's certainly yes an advanced form
of us
so i do like p you said one of your
favorite things about the game was that
it this cool blend of futuristic tech
but also just like stone age
um tools and like a really overgrown
wilderness that you're exploring it's
cool juxtaposition you'll be hunting
like a boar at one point and then you'll
be hunting this sawtooth saber-tooth
machine uh yeah it's a really cool
dichotomy between the two cali i think
you and i have played about the same
amount of time maybe like four or five
hours-ish yeah um what is your take on
this world like are you interested in it
do you want to keep exploring it are you
more interested in the action of the
game um i mean it's like i think they
feed into each other pretty well like
you said going from like you have to
hunt uh mammals for crafting right so
you're going from hunting mammals to
hunting a machine to get the tools to in
turn do something else um and in that
sense like i wanted to learn
more about the world like i'm so
invested in finding out what happened
um
to you know our world to
us you know get the setup for this um
that
you know i want to do the grinding i
want to
get into the action and get the
tools i need to keep exploring um so i
think it does a really good job of that
and i also think i like i at first uh
when i first heard about this game like
when i was first announced i was really
worried about like oh i'm gonna feel so
underpowered with a friggin arrow
against a machine but it doesn't feel
like that and i think it uh
horizon balances that really well also
like
uh
like pete said like you
um
are always given
the information tools you need to take
something down it's a matter of
execution yeah yeah and um
execution that relies on you know you
having to run and dodge and roll out of
harm's way it's so good and managing a
bunch of different weapons like you'll
have a slingshot you'll have you know a
few types of bows
to fire different types of arrows and
you're juggling all of this on the fly
and the game does a really good job of
allowing you to do this by uh using a
weapon wheel and when you're selecting
with the right stick time will slow down
but you can still
run dodge and jump as aloy yeah so you
you're still in the action while you're
choosing your new weapon on top of that
you can craft while in that weapon wheel
yeah it's so smart so you can do all of
this in the middle of combat so it's
this execution both in the physicality
of reacting to an enemy and managing all
of your stuff at the same time to be an
efficient
you know
person and then so if you see this
glowing bit right here eli can use your
focus to focus on an enemy obviously and
then get sort of like where their weak
points are and those elements will stay
highlighted for a period of time you can
knock those off which will have
different effects on enemies some will
have like a fuel canister hit it with
fire it'll explode and that'll kill
other nearby enemies or set those
enemies ablaze creating a chain reaction
or you can knock off a piece of armor
make them vulnerable in that one spot or
knock off one of their weapons pick it
up yourself and use it against the
monster yeah this is the
all of these options could take place in
a single minute of combat or only one or
two of them could take place in a single
encounter but they're all good no matter
how many you're juggling um it's
yeah
that's totally what kept me going was
feeling like i had this powerful sort of
tool set and it was kind of up to my
imagination and skill to make the most
of it yeah some people some people are
calling out uh saying it's like far cry
primal in a way and i actually get that
reference because you are doing
something similar in far cry primal
you're meeting the tribes which also
at the four hours i'm in the inner tribe
politics and kind of cultural relations
makes me think of far cry primal uh and
of course farka primal uses that you
know that new open world uh that
ubisoft established with far cry 3 or
far cry 2 i guess we're going to go back
farther that kind of you know you unlock
this outpost and that leads to three
more people that can give you quests and
they lead to like four more fetch quests
and it's really engaging kind of a
cascading like waterfall structure of
quest that i really like um but then
horizon introduces more
on like the world building side of
things that i felt far cry primal did um
my chief allure to this game right now
outside of the action that you guys were
talking about and using the tools like
using these primitive tools to take down
these futuristic machines and vice versa
and kind of using the machines later on
in the game to help you against them
which i'm just getting into now and i'm
finding pretty exciting to get these new
tools i i really like the fact that i'm
actually invested in these audio logs
i'm coming across from the old world but
like for from us because yeah
usually in a game i was telling you this
morning pete like i'm i think there's so
many games out now especially open world
games that i
don't take as much time as i would like
to to get into the lore and the
backstory and like the audio logs of a
world but i like it here because
everything you're seeing and uh you know
engaging with is the the weird world the
weird part it's not you're learning the
backstory and the lore of that
fantastical world
in front of you but then the audio logs
are from a time that we're familiar with
or at least like relatively we're like
they're you know humans so when i get it
it's like grounding it and like bringing
some recognition to this world and i
really really like that i don't know if
you've had any experience with that in
terms of the world building yes yeah a
little bit of the audio logs i really
like that i can continue to explore and
just kind of listen at my leisure and
then i can stop and start it and um
i uh i normally when i play an open
world game i like try to explore every
corner and it takes me forever to finish
um but this one
i'm
i'm just so invested in figuring it out
because they d like you said they do
ground it in like oh they're talking
about sort of technology that we're you
know 20 30 years out from um so it's
it seems realistic and plausible and
when you're hearing the audio like
there's a moment at the very beginning
uh when you're still playing as child
aloy where she like sees a dad wishing
his
son happy birthday
and like
that sort of thing where like oh he has
to telecommunicate with his kid because
he's doing whatever he is and then i was
wondering like why is he there what is
he doing like i just think
it's it's really smart in in that it
gives you uh sort of like breadcrumbs
yeah at the start and then i'm like i
could not wait to get to the point where
i could start exploring the metal world
again yeah your imagination kind of like
runs with these things you know um and
it's it's cool to see how the game at
least from my perspective like fulfilled
the things i i thought i saw coming and
then also at times didn't and it wasn't
because like i was wrong it was like i
felt like the game knew
what it was trying to set up but then
you know the developers were like we're
gonna
we're gonna surprise you by you know
bait and switch yeah cool yeah i think i
had a little bit of it spoiled for me
but not enough that i don't care about
what's going on because i really am
invested in this story uh like i said i
think the voice acting is hit or miss i
guess that's just
the case it depends on the character
yeah especially when you're meeting so
many npcs um but yeah for all intents
and purposes this is a really cool take
on like an open world i really love
coming across i think i'm like in the
desert region now or near it and i'm
because you know like we've seen this
taiga mountainous area throughout since
it was revealed what two wee threes ago
we've seen that but then of course you
go to these snowier areas you go to
desert i think there's like a more
jungle area from what i hear yeah it's a
pretty varied world uh i don't think
they ever i mean maybe it's a spoiler i
don't think they ever
particularly say it's this part of earth
they don't they do they don't okay well
either way it's it's it seems like a
microcosm of earth right just different
biomes uh and i don't know maybe you go
to more urban environments i don't know
if that's a spoiler but when you do come
across like vestigial traces of our
world it's really cool the metal places
they call it but they're forbidden and
then you know you get the sense that
they're forbidden because the tribes
don't want us to have that power at
least that's my understanding of it now
like three hours into the game so it's
super interesting i get a sense of
weird reference i get a sense of the uh
shyamalan's the village where they like
don't let them go out yeah they're like
making up
these myths this folklore to prevent
them from wandering too far out of the
boundaries it doesn't go to the same
logical yeah like the boundaries brodie
doesn't trip into a spike pit wearing a
red cloak and wolf mouse sorry i just
pulled that movie
it's not the same but yes i can see the
the parallels there like it is i think
the nora tribe is sort of fearful of
technology because they've seen evidence
of what it can do to people yeah and so
they want to basically like prevent that
from happening again okay and i'm
interested in seeing how these different
tribes interact uh there's like the one
that lives in meridian i forget what
it's called uh
but the karja the carjacking cars i'm
just starting to meet a few of them uh
but yeah i don't know oh yeah that weird
guy hits on you
yeah the dude with the mutton chops oh
yeah i was so uncomfortable i think he
was he the sun prince that he talking
about or is that no he was just some
dude something like
he's not even a karja yeah he sort of
becomes your your buddy over time and i
think at one point he even apologizes
like good for having hit on you but yeah
i mean like it's supposed to be
uncomfortable so i thought that was
effective and he was drunk too i think
oh really i think that was the deal like
i think he's always drunk actually he
said he said he needed a drink second
the dude who came brought him with him
for a drinking second and stuff yeah
it's you're at a party uh for context um
i would like to say i think some of the
uh
tribal lore is a is a little bit of a
shortcut like the you know the
matriarchs and the all mother and uh
it i know in post-post-apocalypse
apocalypses
um
apocalypse apocalypses
goddammit um
uh
does that count for the swear jar um no
anyway i i know you know like the traces
of the old worlds and all the progress
we've made are usually wiped out in a
post post apocalypse so it's like okay
of course we're gonna start from kind of
square one or square zero um but i do
think it's a it's a little bit of a
convenient
uh not a cop-out but i i was kind of at
the very beginning i'm like oh okay a
matriarchy okay
oh you know they worship the goddess all
right um and it just it it seemed like
they were they had
gone too far back into like oh we're
tribes and we make up these myths to
explain the world when like alloy has
this focus and she just gets ever she's
like oh right so it's okay
it's why like almost immediately that
tribal stuff just feels long in the
tooth especially like you know it i
played the game for about 60 hours and
i'd say about 20 hours in the story
starts to really focus outside of the
tribal stuff so thankful for it because
it really just doesn't
doesn't add up to a lot you sort of like
there is a conflict that arises you
understand it there's not like the
moving pieces within it they're not that
great
yeah i'm also a little wary of it just
because um i'm not sure what
uh
current world inspiration they have for
the tribes it's it feels like they're
wearing like native american inspired
garb i mean yeah the matriarchy is like
a very i mean where i'm from in the
northeast the iroquois tribes are all
like it was matriarchal and also
creation story sounds sort of similar
too yeah i mean well they didn't have a
super ai
there's a there's a lot of stuff that is
that seems very reminiscent of native
american culture
on one hand the game is like really good
at putting um you know females at the
front of the game not just aloy but
other characters that are females are
really strong and that's nice to see
and you also see a lot of like people of
color as well which is great definitely
like i'd say the vast majority in this
game are
but then eloy is cast as this white girl
like wearing all this tribal stuff i
mean like it's
it's like one step in the right
direction
we were talking about this yesterday not
to nitpick but would there even be many
white people this far in the future
wasn't there a national geographic thing
about how like that there wouldn't be
white people right i so i feel weird
talking about this as like three irish
as hell white people but um
i it did give me pause no certain
absolutely it's not just being it's not
just looking for things to be sensitive
about no this is blatant i would i would
love for somebody who's more uh
well-versed in the topic than i um to
give their take on it like i would love
to read that or hear that like tweet at
me i would love to know more but um yes
so i was i was a little hesitant about
it i'm like okay they're wearing like a
lot of beads and some people have dreads
and they're that's okay
that's the thing aloy doesn't have
dreads by that she looks like she has
dreads i was talking to somebody about
this i'm like this white girl with red
hair and dreads and i'm like her hair
when i'm
and when i don't blow my hair dryer and
straighten it that's how my hair looks
so
well yeah different color
yeah oh yeah really no i wish i could do
dreadlocks but no you don't
yeah the uh and i just find it
interesting her name is
almost alloy yeah which is a mixture of
metals so we'll see where that goes
story-wise i don't know i'm not spelling
anything yeah maybe she really is just a
machine
i have no idea um anyway cool so yeah
that's we just wanted to talk about the
world building itself of the game
because it is kind of a pretty novel way
of taking on the post-post apocalypse uh
and that's a good segue into our next
section uh oh before i go on uh twitch
user miblik as well as a few other
people are asking what the game's
release date is correct me if i'm wrong
it's february 28th on ps4 yes so a week
from yesterday
yes so next tuesday yes this coming
tuesday it's way easier way to say it
february 28th uh yes let us know what
you think about the world building uh
hopefully we'll have more to talk about
next week when you play it again because
we always want to have you involved we
don't want to be talking about these
things to you we want to hear your
feedback so let us know on twitter pete
brown kelly plaggy mike mchardy we'll
respond to you cool so moving on that's
a good segue um
i think one of the surprising things
that like it's weird a lot of times you
know certain reviewers and certain
outlets don't like to talk about too
much about the intent behind the game or
like what like the developer what it
means for the developer but it's kind of
hard to separate the story of gorilla
games from horizon zero dawn mainly
because the only thing they've done
before is this drab action shooter
franchise they did have a game before
kill zones sorry the biggest thing
they've done well certainly ever since
their first game although all kills i
think it's been like 12 years or
something like that yeah and now you
know after the three kill zones and then
kills on shadow fall which is pretty
much just showing off the tech of the
ps4 they're here with horizon zero dawn
which you know it's an amalgamation of a
few different kinds of games action rpg
open world but
it's cool they made the jump pretty
gracefully
i
based on
my feelings about the evolution of
killzone i didn't care about this game
at all yeah i didn't even plan on
reviewing it um i sort of had to pick it
up due to circumstances
i was so pleasantly surprised and it has
totally overwritten my perception of
guerrilla games like i'd
kill zone is like
that's history i don't even i i can't
even factor that in anymore
it was a shell shock nom 67 yeah
dumb name um but yeah it's for all they
it is cool because like the story seems
it's a weird thing like i'm so we're
going to talk again in a few minutes
about uh open world games in general and
whether they're kind of
whether the genre is just this big
amorphous blob right now i think horizon
does some cool things to set it apart
and then you know we have breath in the
wild and the horizon and last year we
had a few of them but
um i just sat on the horizon again i've
been saying it way too much that was
accidental that time um i it's yeah it
is
impressive as hell that they could have
made this jump so well and introduce
their own ideas into the fray at the
same time i don't know um
what
we want to get into other developers but
like did you play killzone at all cali
barely yeah you like shooters a lot i do
they were pretty boring shooters yeah i
mean as far as shooter shooters go i i
play a lot of them there was nothing
really to draw me
in uh to killzone so i barely touched it
um
yeah i mean just i just going from first
person shooter to third person action
alone with disregarding everything else
about horizon is a big jump to me like
it's impressive enough to me like oh
that's a completely different mindset
different level design different
everything yeah it seems like they
definitely establish themselves here
with a new like show that they can do
you know one-trick pony so to speak um
so gorilla games for all intense
purposes looks like they're doing well
and we want to talk about other
developers that might be like hot right
now for lack of a better term uh at the
present time or even developers that we
like
have done no wrong it would seem uh
i wanted to go first i think blizzard
entertainment consistently does the same
thing i think for the most part um i
think overwatch their first big shooter
was
a
huge success it's one of my favorite
shooters ever now i was one of my
favorite games last year uh blizzard has
this uncanny ability to understand what
makes a genre great and kind of boil it
down to its maybe not bare essentials
but boil it down to its essence and then
you know
blow things up from there uh overwatch
itself is just like great team tutor
great tactics uh just the characters how
they interplay with each other i
actually think i've talked about it
before the world building of overwatch
despite the fact it's not right in your
face it's some of my favorite in the
game
uh in recent memory uh but of course you
know they went from you know like start
with warcraft and they jump to starcraft
they have two rts properties um you have
world of warcraft which shows no signs
of slowing down in the mmo space or i
mean show signs of slowing down but it's
still pretty huge for being how many
years old 14
yeah
like 13 years old that's crazy me and
then they still have how many
subscribers
millions michael
millions
of people in azeroth every day they got
that that those pandas now that panda
expansion and i like diablo iii
despite the fact that a lot of people
don't eric tay is probably like throwing
up right now but i really like diablo 3.
uh it's one of my favorite games i
realized that it skewed a lot of what
made the elbow too good but they could
do an action rpg like no other and
they've every time they jump genres like
who knows what would happen with titan
but that would have been an mmo as well
so
you know
they for all intents purposes are doing
really well mm-hmm um i don't know pete
you have a developer in mind that you
think is kind of
we talked about this yesterday and now
i'm trying
i know like you mentioned a few um like
cali you mentioned the fulbright company
yes
indie space yeah as far as indies go um
i've gone home as one of my favorite
games um and that's the reason i want to
play tacoma like aside from everything
that i know about tacoma which isn't
actually that much i know the setting
and kind of like what it's like space
adventure
thing um but i will play it simply
because it's full bright and i know that
they do a good job and uh now that nina
freeman works at fulbright um i really
liked uh how do you do it which is like
this little experimental um like flash i
think game that she did um
now that she does level design over
there i have even more incentive to to
be interested in tacoma even without
knowing that much so that's kind of
aside from aaa stuff that they're the
ones i'm keeping my eye on for now yeah
uh gone home was great i loved every
second of it uh i haven't replayed it i
don't think since i finished it but
tacoma i'm hoping will scratch that itch
especially you know set on a space
station it looks kind of like it has
system shock vibes almost not that it's
a first person
sim shooter like prey is but i'm really
looking forward to
tacoma and actually that's a good segue
arcane studios uh
since they released dishonored in 2012
it seems like they've just been nailing
it i mean designer two is the only other
game and now they have prey which looks
fantastic it looks right up my alley
it's more open world than dishonored
it's sci-fi horror yes so so sold on
prey yes so can't wait for it um and i
feel like arcane
for several reasons you know they're
bringing back that first-person
immersive sim uh
story-driven shooter that you know like
system shock uh deus ex back in the day
with origin systems and looking glass
studios they were pioneering it but it
just didn't always catch on because you
have to be pretty patient to play those
kind of games i don't think that was a
time before people realize how
intelligent games could be with their
systems and in internet i just want to
play doom man what is this yeah doom
yeah
which is nothing wrong with that no but
yeah no i mean back in the day you know
i know yeah i was like excuse me
arcane studio is like continuously
impressing me like
dishonored two
i'm playing through it for the second
time on and off right now and i'm loving
it and i'm pretty excited to see what
they do with pray and see now they're
like ralph cole antonio is at the front
i love saying his name yeah rafael
he's at the he's at the head of prey
and he's saying at least once a day to
me somehow you find a way to fit that
um and yeah in general if
like and with harvey smith the head of
uh dishonored why do you have to throw
me off like that
all right keep up with me man
he's not
spanish like i'm applying without
accents
but anyway it's uh oh my god
kind of always just you know seems like
they can do no wrong right now that's
hoping that
holds up on may 5th when prey releases
um i don't know what other developers
are there like that are always like i
feel like rockstar is it's me twitch
chat jump from gta two to three was
pretty significant yeah did someone say
naughty dog it looks like foam knuckles
said he's an uncharted lover arguing
over naughty dog i think okay i was
gonna say naughty dog i don't
dislike anything except for like
uncharted one i mean they were rather
than jumping genres like um
gorilla games did we we were just
talking about you can look at naughty
dog and see this gradual logical
evolution right you start with crash
bandicoot the third person like
barebones third person platformer action
game on the first playstation then
uncharted and there you go and then
you go to jack and dexter which is more
of the evolution of that third-person
shooter
mechanics in it in wider worlds then you
go to uncharted this like kind of grand
adventure with set pieces uh by the time
you get to uncharted 3 you have the last
of us right around the corner it's a
much more bleak and much more
story-driven
you know third-person adventure and kind
of like shooting mechanics survival
mechanics uncharted 4 rolls around
uh some jamock at gamespot gave it a 10
out of 10 but it's a fantastic game in
its own right ah that was me i really
like this game you're that gentleman i
think everybody should play on charter
four uh for various reasons and you can
read my review
if you want to it's up on the site go
check out 10 out of 10. yeah it's
outdated uh we've lost legacy on the
horizon maybe you should play on chart
four if you haven't finished it did you
play a chart for kelly
i've never played an uncharted i don't
know anything interesting i was like you
until a few months ago yeah four is a
great place to start really yeah for
real oddly enough i played like 10
minutes of one when it first came out
and i was like screw this [ __ ] oh
and then i played uncharted 4. feed the
f-bombs for those who can't see i am
placing a dollar inside the f-bomb we'll
figure out what to do with the money
later on but it is in there we can buy
ourselves a nice pizza anyway um
uncharted 4 is great because it's you
don't really need all the history of the
characters or the games okay it tells a
compelling story
uh yeah uh buckybitz on twitch said
valve question mark earlier a little bit
earlier i mean i feel like valve is so
different than what it used to be now
it's just so esports focused and very
just dota 2. and i'm sure well i know
they have and then all their proprietary
stuff and their hardware to boot but i'm
sure they have a lot of stuff they're
working on but who knows what it is yeah
yeah
not quite on topic but kind of similar
discussion about a developer that went
from perhaps a relevance to utter
relevance is psionics yeah yeah yeah i
mean rocket don't need to tell you guys
the story of rocket league it's
incredible uh the first version of that
game that came out in like 2008 or nine
super super
acrobatic supersonic acrobatic rocket
powered battle cars yeah we need a jinx
jar
uh that game
it didn't have legs and uh we just leave
it at that
god
but what about what about rocket league
does it rocket league has so many legs
it's got wheels
about losing a dollar super sonic
acrobatic rocket probably better college
battle cars it does not have wheels but
rocket league has
wheels it has nos it has
machine guns that come out of the hood
of the cars in the dlc which is upcoming
no i'm just kidding um oh my god but you
do have that thing with the the splendid
splunger
the weapon plunger that's the word you
played much of the um
what's the mode with all the i got i get
so sick of that you have nitrous
damn that's the ugliest car ever that's
real i'm a masamune person no you would
be
um oh yeah euro yeah yeah at this table
i said manga once and yeah
okay um what is what are the developers
we have here i mentioned yeah rockstar
we kind of got into briefly um i have
one i want to bring up to you because
i'm sure you have an opinion about it um
from software i think most things from
software does is just great
i mean i think they're a little more
relevant now
you're the giant
the beginning of the show we showed this
yorum the giant uh giveaway i don't feel
like picking it back up but uh it's
relevant because dark souls 3 has dlc
incoming eric tay would know when it's
about a month or two away uh kind of
amid this spring release schedule uh
everything from does is some sort of
excellent uh i gave dark souls 3 an 8
out of 10. i felt like it got a little
repetitive in the late game and the
bosses stopped being interesting same
problem i'm having with neo actually but
i really like both neo and dark souls 3
but bloodborne is one of my favorite
games and anything from oh this is my
footage i think
anything from software does is uh just
in general i'd expect it to be fantastic
and they haven't let me down yet so i
don't have any reason to expect they
might you should play some of their old
games
yeah right like before demon souls what
was uh what was kingdom something
kingdom oh it was kingsfield kingsville
the series they worked on that that
looked like ultima underworld first
person like rpg sim yes dungeon crawler
yeah
um and of course they made a lot of
armored core games which were very hit
or miss yeah but since demon souls i
feel like they've yeah nailed it more or
less speaking of
someone that used to be kind of
you so with joe danger joe joe changer
uh hello games kind of jump genres with
no man's sky a contentious game of 2016.
people got what they wanted some people
did not some people felt like promises
were broken some people felt like
marketing led them astray
but
like it or loved it no man's sky was
very different from joe danger hello
game's previous series yeah uh pete
what's your thoughts on the jump they
made
uh they took away the motorcycle yeah
they made a boy show it's a good show
well i role played as joe the whole time
um yeah obviously they expanded this
huge you know universe with all these i
guess it was a galaxy uh galaxy with all
these planets and star systems and all
this great stuff uh it's just like joe
danger was uh like here's a motorcycle
you're gonna rev up and go off a jump
get some points like this is not that
and i think you defend no man's sky more
than a lot of people yeah i'll defend it
do it to near death do it near death
near death i won't die for it uh
whenever i think about no man's sky i
think about that video uh where they
played like the janky jurassic park yeah
yeah and then
we all did it i couldn't i found i
couldn't find enough substance in no
man's sky grant i only played for four
hours but i couldn't find enough can i
ask you where you played it was it at
home by yourself
was eric taylor there bothering you
such an inside joke
no not at the time this is one of my
former roommates who
made things not enjoyable sometimes uh
you're watching eric yeah hey you're
watching uh no i was playing at home and
uh
yeah for about four hours one night and
then oh and then i left for a trip for
work and then i never came back to it
afterward yeah so i immersed myself for
like a week straight just like not
moving i had the perfect butt groove in
the couch i mean i literally spent as
much time as i was a cat i was like
why is my butt groove moaning yeah uh i
spent
as much time as i could by myself
playing it
that's bad
um it's team yeah like i i really had to
immerse myself in the adventure you know
and i really just kind of um that's what
did it for me like if you look at it
from like a bullet point or like a
checklist kind of things like oh does it
do these things that they told me it
would do no it doesn't really add up
uh but kind of like horizon i didn't
really pay attention to no man's sky
because i didn't think it was going to
be a game for me and kind of like
horizon i just fell into it
for what it was i thought it was
actually very impressive it's also not i
mean it's different when you don't work
in games i guess but like i i definitely
work very hard not to evaluate a game
based on what i expected from it like i
want to take it for what it is uh which
is is very different for if you're you
know
just like you were really excited for
this game you saw the trailers you saw
all the hype for it and then you got
something that was different um
i think you know being on either sides
of that
fence uh you're gonna have different
opinions about no man's sky totally yeah
um yeah and then i did want to mention
uh rockstar quick i keep bringing it up
but i feel like everything they do is
pretty
you know spot-on yeah table tennis game
was okay yeah dude one rockstar game
i've never played that i always get
yelled at for is bully you ever play
bully you've never played bully oh my
god oh my god
oh my god
i've never played bully oh my god
you haven't played bully you've been
playing bully uh tell us about bully uh
so they did not miss the mark with this
i take it so well okay so the other
weekend i got really drunk and played
bully which was really fun because i
kept wanting to go to english class i
get drunk and bully people
adults
they can take it
depending on your age i'll throw
something more lethal at you
and depending on my goodness
yeah
someone draw that graph of like the
parabola anyway uh yeah i mean it's you
just go around you punch people and you
go to class and you kiss girls and you
can kiss boys so you know very ahead of
its time it's like play pranks right
yeah and you just yeah and there's like
like i did halloween but like i said i
was super drunk i'm a writer so i was
like i can't wait to go to english class
and be smart in english um
uh drink responsibly and um
i had your grenades
yeah um
but it's it's just like one of those
i don't even i wouldn't call it a cult
davis is getting away but davis is
getting away there's a permanent upper
third telling you that there's something
there's something so like stupidly fun
about it are you at the school the whole
time
um no you can go in town uh you can go
on like a festival date with a girl i
couldn't figure out how to get to the
festival i tried swimming in the ocean
and it didn't work and then she dumped
me but you tried swimming to get to the
festival yeah because it was like across
the bay
oh getting whaled on
when we move on from bully if you're
is that everything is that enough yeah
that's basically what i wanted to say
about yeah so rockstar doesn't always
disappoint to say the least uh they
haven't really jumped genres too much
but you know they are capable like max
payne 3 wasn't an open world game but
that was still a fantastic third person
shooter one of my favorite uh i do want
to talk about someone that seems on the
decline pete that you mentioned
yesterday they have nier automata on the
platinum um
what a weird story i mean it felt like
for years they could do no wrong like
they were just kind of like every beat
was like yes yes yes then then a group
of
mutant turtles came along last year in
manhattan
new york uh yeah it was i think it was
korra was the first game or maybe
turtles came first but they've had a
slew of like licensed games like
transformers was apparently okay
because it didn't really reach too far
and it sort of delivered this like cool
like 80s action game but yeah turtles
cora
by the way the polygon review for
turtles is like the funniest review i've
ever read is that justin no i don't
remember who wrote it oh maybe it was
maybe it was just it's so funny it's
really funny yeah go read that um
yeah and they seem to be slipping a
little bit and who knows
where the buck falls when it comes to um
the xbox one game
dragon
scale bound yeah
dragon we're professionals
uh who knows whose fault that is but the
story of platinum is a bit strange at
this point uh to see you know
i'm reading it right now it's justin
mcelroy okay so funny to read some you
know to see some of their failures and
then to sort of see a game like this a
big one get cancelled is pretty big
indication of some problems as is the
president leaving the company
what what is happening with them i don't
know i don't i don't think they're out
of great ideas like the new near is
really fun from what i've played in
preview events that girl's outfit love
it totally cool cosplay
it it it hits all the the right like
buttons for me in terms of action and
presentation and like platinum
creativity when it comes to like just
mixing that all together and something
really fascinating and fun
but
you know what else do they have right
now it's
they're making a game with the people
who made final fantasy tactics but it's
for mobile like yeah there's all this
like weird stuff where i feel like the
stuff that people really want from them
is sort of like a side project for
platinum now right it had to adapt to
the market and it seems like their
reputation which is already kind of at a
low point hinges on the sequel to a cult
classic yeah near which not a lot of
people played i'm looking forward to
automata a lot
really fun from what i play the um the
platinum mechanics feel really great but
i don't know if that's gonna be enough
to like elevate them again i mean
they clearly have the talent in-house i
don't think it's a slight to anyone who
works there or creates games for them to
to sort of look at platinum this way
it's just the business decisions and the
projects that are being taken on
i don't know and maybe they're just not
given the same treatment among the teams
right certain people go to play or
develop certain games other ones work on
the uh license stuff yep yeah i don't
know it harms the reputation of the
company a little bit yeah are you
looking forward to near automotive
yeah yeah i tell everybody i didn't play
the original i just um
it's like i want to jump into it now
yeah that there's a new one coming out
did you play drakengard 3 because
apparently this is like something of a
spiritual successor wait really
yeah oh cool i've never played dragon
ball i haven't played that one but
that's cool that sounds like something
you might play probably
not an insult i
i say dragon guard knowing you it could
be an insult what would mike play mike
would play uh
wii sports resort
at least give me like nintendo land
no you'd play wii sports resort just for
a workout
whatever all right moving on so uh if we
didn't mention any developers that you
think jump genres with really well or
any developers that are kind of hot
right now doing a good job with their
recent releases or any that you are
excited for let us know hit us up on
twitter pete brown callie plaggy mike
mchardy and uh yeah leave your thoughts
in the comment below if you're watching
this on youtube all right last segment
we're going back to horizon for one last
thing uh nintendo switch releases march
3rd
wait really yeah
nice i don't know
i didn't like double check
what we could talk about so i'm just
gonna not talk about stuff just ask
questions and i will
okay answer appropriately okay so breath
of the wild is on
is about to release uh it's an open
world game we were talking about open
world games before yes
i'm confirming
it'll be be made by nintendo yes
in japan yes it'll be on the nintendo
switch yes and the wii u and the wii u
don't forget about that the wii u is
zelda's nintendo's previous console yes
this has gone on
um
and we want to talk about whether
horizon zero dawn because it was so
surprising as an overall game will
hold you over until breath of the wild
comes out if not even compete with it in
terms of an open world game right
because uh breath of the wild for what
we've seen is the closest zelda hasn't
got back to that first zelda which is
completely open just more like
emphasizing exploration but obviously to
like
the hundredth degree in this case on the
nintendo switch just just times 100.
take the first cell to multiply it by
100 that's what you get that's 100th
degree and times 100 are very different
i know but
i don't want to talk about exponents
right now i just
want to talk about whether horizon zero
dawn will hold you over until breath of
the wild comes out in terms of being an
open world guy right so based on my
previous experience playing zelda at
events right like e3 and stuff i'm
trying to contextualize where i'm
presenting this interf okay i can walk
off set it's cool
don't do all right so
yes all the things you said were true
like having [ __ ] embargoes
all right
all right all right so having played a
little bit of breath of the wild in the
past and then jumping into horizon yes i
immediately had that feeling of
crap am i spoiling breath of the wild
for myself by playing this game right
open world survival's a thing bow and
arrow is you know like what you use most
of the time and that was some of the
source of some of the best footage of
breath of the wild like the slo-mo bow
shots like oh damn that's in horizon
right
well uh
after going through horizon i can
certainly say that what i expect from
zelda horizon gave me something
different there are certain parallels to
be drawn
i think you can play both games and not
get burnt out i mean time will tell
but but certainly horizon is its own
beast but it definitely has that like if
you need like a taste of zelda if you
can't get it right away but you have a
ps4
i encourage you to try horizon because
it offers similar things mechanically it
seems like there's much more from what i
know of breath of the wild it seems like
there is much more room for
emergent situations
like things happening that you might not
initially even consider because i know
that happens in horizon a little bit but
it seems like zelda you can like from
what we saw you can snowboard down the
slope on that thing you can jump off and
paraglide those are mechanical layers
right but that means in terms of like in
terms of like not knowing that if you're
in a thunderstorm this okay this metal
suit is gonna shock you i don't see as
many like um
you know
unfactored situations happening that
might happen in breath of the wild in
horizon zero dawn because i've been
playing like four or five hours of this
and
it seems a little more predictable than
zelda not a bad way um it just seems
more condensed zelda seems like there
are way more overlapping mechanics i
mean in in a way you could say because
yes based on all the footage coming out
of like previous events one of the
things people were talking about was did
you see this thing in breath of the wild
what you can do that no did you see this
thing oh my god like yeah everybody did
something different right that was the
story there and so horizon is in in that
context a simpler game
um zelda certainly will have a lot of
surprises based on what we've seen up to
this point like it seems to indicate
that like you're gonna have to learn
things on the fly especially the
beginning of horizon is a lot more
linear yeah uh when you get a little bit
of time to do side questing and stuff
but uh
when we like at e3 when everybody was
playing demos of zelda it was like i
went to a mountain what there was a
mountain oh yeah and i didn't have
clothes on so i froze like you were
naked yeah like wait you didn't have
clothes on like so um yeah in that sense
i think what we've been exposed to so
far
uh has been a lot less linear than maybe
what uh your initial like what you know
about horizon if you haven't
seen anything but like previews uh
it's it's less linear than what you've
seen from that yeah josh shaw and twitch
chat is saying that they're going to be
different because one's japanese the
other is western is way too reductive
josh well is horizon horizon's western
style but it's not a western oh yeah
it's from amsterdam i mean yeah i think
you can look at maybe just that that
quintessential nintendo charm
and see how
no game can ever really replicate that
as well as a nintendo game link is like
such a dork and i love that about him
heroes good like when you
yeah but it's different
people did like that
um when like when he cooks he's humming
and stuff and it's just a it's a very
different
uh
character perspective i guess um if that
makes sense like like horizon is much
more like
there's some serious [ __ ] going oh [ __ ]
um yeah
everyone's speeding
just for the record i gave both of them
the dollars they put in there yeah okay
you know okay i'll give you a dollar
when we leave yeah for the recognize us
for the record no one can see me on
camera or not but i'm not posing with
the camera that's not relevant look i
have a dollar
i have a dollar just it's not
patronizing obviously stop condescending
to me no i'm a patron nope those aren't
the opposite anyway um
condescending and patronizing are not
the same they're not the same but
they're not they're pretty opposite no
they're not one is putting someone down
one is like trying to make someone else
feel better by putting no they're not
opposites um
no you start you forfeited the words uh
you forfeited editorship so you don't
get to tell me what words mean
video team get portrayed anyway
uh yeah or like what we're seeing here
right now just bring it back uh
like the uh moving the environment
versus in horizon there's much more uh
you know using the environment to do
things for you like you don't use the
environment the same way so you're
harvesting things from the environment
but like
what i've seen from breath of the wild
what i've played of breath of the wild
is very much uh
like finding clever ways to interact
with the environment if that makes sense
yeah like how do i chop down a tree
without an axe well i can figure it out
maybe yeah you know it's weird because
breath of the wild's world is gorgeous
and doesn't initially seem dangerous but
from what i've actually played it is and
survival's a big part of it whereas yeah
horizon
seems very dangerous but
less dangerous yeah yeah it's still
dangerous i mean there are some tough
animals to fight but i haven't had too
much trouble yet the game is very
generous in terms of being like you can
just pick up plants and keep them in
your pocket and when you need to need to
munch some for health do it whatever
like you can or you can make a healthy
potion yeah
you can heal yourself pretty readily
in um
horizon yeah i would be remissed if i
did not get to some of the twitter
questions we had earlier this week about
horizon don't be remiss um
remiss what did i say or missed i'm
sorry i'm just okay let's not do this
grammar thing now
we don't need that on okay
page three glamour babes he really is
mac he's not mac he's dennis he's
definitely so difficult as hell yeah
they're talking about it's always sunny
if you don't have the instructor
page three glamour babe from twitter was
saying how long is the game are there
any side missions quest to do yeah there
are side missions and quests for sure
yeah i mean i spent about 60 hours 82
completion rating and i didn't focus on
side quests that often yeah um daniel
nas said thoughts on the best game
developers sony has exclusives with all
of them
i don't think it's true
there are there are more quote unquote
best game developers out there yes uh am
i going to be able to hunt animals or is
it just machines that's about horizon
which i'm sure i'm concerned you also
hunt animals and they are a source of
the sort of natural resources like bones
and hides that you use to create pouches
and you also use them for a few other
things
meat can be used for health potions and
stuff like that okay yeah there's like
isn't there different kinds of meat
there's like bony meat and
fatty meat fatty meat rich meat right
which how is that different from fatty
meat i don't know fatty as fatty rich is
uh rich cannots
fat richard who richard richard
the richard meat yeah um
so yeah let us know what you think or
let us know what you think will horizon
zero dawn hold you over until a breath
of the wild comes out let us know next
week once you play we'll circle back to
it uh we'll be on twitter obviously pete
brown kelly plagging mike mchardy let us
know what you think of horizon once you
play it next week or if you've already
played it i don't know depending on what
your profession is uh and let us know
what you think about it and uh yeah that
is a lot of horizon talk today sure yeah
so
uh that's pretty much our show uh i do
want to bring this
monstrosity uh [ __ ] sorry so this is the
giveaway we mentioned at the beginning
of the show um it's the giant from dark
souls 3 if you're familiar it's a really
bad boss fight from the game but a cool
figure
um
hey you said [ __ ] bro where's my dollar
yeah you gotta put another dollar in you
swore again i don't have another dollar
um daddy warbucks over here yeah so
uh gamespot is going to be tweeting this
it will be uh
i don't need your money oh you're so
condescending oh but i'm sorry you're
bigger than the swear jargon you don't
have it okay fine
i'll pay you back
uh yeah we will gamespot has tweeted uh
the link to this giveaway uh so enter
your name follow gamespot retweet that
tweet and later on the week we will pick
a winner and maybe you'll get this 30
pound norm the giant he's really like 20
pounds
who he's 20 pounds i'm close i had 17
pounds but anyway thanks so much for the
guys in the back john luke typekey
richard lee eric tay
uh we're gonna have a good show next
week we'll be able to talk more about
some nintendo stuff yes switch and not
zelda or zelda we could talk about we
could talk more about zelda not that we
have it in our office
i wish yeah
this is so stupid
uh so yeah thanks as always for joining
us for the week we will be back here
next week at 11 a.m on wednesday here in
san francisco california thanks so much
for joining we'll see you next time
[Music]
oh my god how do i respond to a guy that
has japanese in the front
i can't like search his name like i
can't type back to that guy
you